[Music]
after months of testing ANCOVA 19
patients the World Health Organization
says it's ending trials of anti malaria
drug hydroxychloroquine which President
Trump touted and took himself as well
the UN agency also ending kovat 19
trials of a combo of HIV drugs saying
that they and hydroxychloroquine
produced quote little or no reduction in
the mortality of hospitalized kovat 19
patients when compared to standard care
joining us now family and emergency
medicine dr. Janet Nashua a Fox News
contributor as well dr. Nashua thanks so
much for joining us here talking about
hydroxychloroquine it always seems like
there's this aura of politics around it
because the President himself
acknowledged he took it a two week
course the doctor there saying there was
no harm that came of that but it proved
a very controversial the president
criticized as possibly putting people
who might take the drug as well in
danger since then there's been all sorts
of reporting on this and studies into
the drug now this latest from the World
Health Organization your thoughts on
their results yes so initially Molly you
know this is a new virus and we were
desperate to try anything that could
potentially save lives and we had some
initial initial anecdotal evidence that
showed that this drug may have been
therapeutic and may have helped to save
lives and those who were severely ill
and hospitalized on ventilators so what
the World Health Organization just did
is they halted what's called the
Solidarity trial and again this is a
trial that included three different
medications not just hydroxy pork and
alone it included two HIV medicines plus
hydroxyl Klerk and what it showed was
there was no significant reduction in
mortality and those who are hospitalized
and those who were really ill it also
did not show any increase in mortality
meaning this trial these medications did
not cause any harm to these patients who
were hospitalized and it also does not
affect the potential study and use in
the preventive use of this medication so
that's really important but you know
like you said there's so many studies
out there some that shows that it's
helpful some that show that it's harmful
the most recent study that just came out
published
the Journal of infectious diseases at
the hospital of Henry Ford in Michigan
showed that about 13% of 2500 patients
had a mortality reduction if they were
put on hydroxyl klerken versus 26
percent mortality and those who were not
on it so you know it's something that
you have to talk to your doctor about
again there's still a lot more studies
that need to be conducted but
fortunately we have other medications
and other therapeutics evolving such as
REM death severe as steroids
dexamethasone and you know convalescent
plasma is very important as well as the
vaccine that's under development right
now and then monoclonal antibodies are
really important so we've got a lot
under development in the pipeline's this
is just another study to show that hey
it might work and then of course we have
all these other studies that show that
it may not so we have to wait buttons I
was reading that as well the team at
Henry Ford health systems out of
Michigan's that study 2541 hospitalized
patients of course the goal in all of
this is to not become hospitalized
unfortunately there are a number of
states Arizona Florida Texas all seeing
were enormous spikes in numbers Texas
seeing some record-breaking cases
Florida also reporting record-breaking
cases particularly in miami-dade and
Broward counties now public officials
are basically pleading with the public
to wear masks but is that enough or does
there need to be more of an effort to
self isolate what you know how do we
traumatic this tie that is so
frightening there in the Sun Belt yeah
so it's multifactorial you know it's a
combination of facial covering physical
distance in keeping your hands washed
and cleaned avoiding large crowds so the
spread of this virus is propagated
initially I think in Florida from
opening of the bars and the restaurants
and the closed person-to-person
interaction and then of course the lack
of compliant but you know the governor's
they're taking action they're scaling
back they're shutting down the bars and
the restaurants temporarily they've shut
down the beaches to try to mitigate the
you know transmission of this virus and
then plus we if they remember there's a
potential mutation in this virus which
makes it up to 10 times more
transmissible so perhaps Florida Texas
Arizona these states that have opened
may be seeing an increase in the number
of cases because
of that potential mutation as well not
just the lack of compliance so we really
need to get on tout on target and make
sure that we encourage everyone if you
are unable to social distance cover your
cover your face because that's how this
virus spreads from one person to another
by aerosolizing the virus though we have
no tools we have the knowledge we just
gotta adhere to it dr. Janet Nashua
thank you so much for joining us today
we appreciate it yeah